luis receives a gift card worth twenty
five dollars to an online retailer that
sells digital music and games
each song costs one dollar and each game
costs two dollars he wants to buy at
least 15 items with his card
set up a system of inequalities that
represents this scenario and identify
the range of possible purchases using a
graph so let's define some variables
here
let's let
let's let's he's going to buy music in
game so let's let m equal the number
of songs
the number of songs he buys and let g
let g be equal to the number of games
actually just so it's more intuitive
let's let s be the number of songs
let's let s
lets s be the number of songs
number of songs
and lets let g
be equal to the number
of games
that he buys so they give us some
information here they say that he wants
to buy at least
15 items with this card so that means
that the total number of items the
number of songs plus the number of games
have to be at least 15. so this sentence
right here tells us that s
plus g that's the total number of items
it has to be at least 15. so it has to
be greater than or equal to 15. it can
be 15 or larger it could be 16 17 18 so
on and so forth it also tells us it also
tells us that he has a gift card worth
and each song costs one dollar and each
game cost two dollars so he can't spend
any more than 25 dollars so how much is
he going to spend as a function of the
songs and the games so each song costs
one dollar so he's going to spend the
number of dollars times the number of
songs so if he buys ten songs he's going
to spend ten dollars plus
for each game he's going to spend two
dollars plus two times the number of
games so if he buys five songs in five
games the five songs are gonna cost five
dollars five times one plus
five times two for the games plus ten so
it's going to be fifteen dollars so this
is how much he spends on songs and games
i could have put a one out here four
dollars but this is how much he spent or
won for it's one dollar per song but
this is how much he spends in dollars on
songs and games and he only has a gift
card worth 25 dollars so it has to be
the total amount he spends has to be
less than or equal to 25 dollars he can
spend exactly 25 if he has to he just
can't spend 25 dollars and one cent so
we have a system of inequalities here
and now we can essentially graph them
and so to graph them
we just have to pick one something to go
on the vertical axis and the negative
and the horizontal axis and actually i'm
only going to draw the first quadrant
here since he's only going to buy a
positive number of songs and games so
let's let the songs on the vertical axis
and let's let the games on the
horizontal axis
and then what i like to do is i like to
express it in terms of or i like if i'm
putting s as the vertical axis i like to
solve for s so it kind of goes in the
traditional slope intercept form so this
first thing up here if we subtract g
from both sides of this we get that the
songs have to be greater than or equal
to
negative g
plus 15
and then this one over here if we
subtract 2g from both sides i want to do
that same magenta color
if we subtract 2g from both sides so
that we isolate the s on the left we get
s is less than or equal to negative 2g
negative 2g
plus 25. and now we can try to graph
these and we could just look at points
or we could look at slope
the slope intercept of the boundary line
but let's just look at so over here if g
if
he buys no games then s is going to be
let's just think about the boundary line
here so the boundary line for this
constraint over here is going to be s is
equal to negative g plus 15. so if he
buys no games he will buy 15 songs so
let's make this 5
15 songs so the s intercept we could say
is 15. if he buys no games he'll buy 15
songs
based on that constraint
now what happens if he buys no songs if
he buys no songs then you have 0 is
equal to negative g plus 15 or you could
say that g is equal to 15. so if he buys
no songs then he's going to have to buy
15 games
so it's 5
and 15.
so that would be a point on the boundary
line and we're actually going to include
the boundary lines it's greater than or
equal to greater than or equal to so
i'll draw a solid line here
i will draw a solid line there so this
is our boundary line but it's not just
the boundary line it's not s plus g is
equal to 15 it's s plus g has to be
greater than or equal to 15 or s is
greater than or equal to negative g plus
15. so when you look at it this way you
see that s for any g
for any g
negative g plus 15 is going to hit the
line
or it's going to hit right at the
boundary line for the s but it's that s
and any of the s's that are greater so
we're going to be above the line
and if you just want to make sure you
can verify that we're above the line you
can try something that's on the other
side of the line maybe zero zero zero
zero definitely doesn't work zero plus
zero is not greater than or equal to
fifteen and if you try something out
here like fifteen comma fifteen fifteen
plus fifteen is 30 which is greater than
or equal to 15. so we feel pretty good
there's this whole area above the line
and now look at let's look at this
second constraint the boundary line is s
is equal to negative 2g
plus 25. so once again the s-intercept
or if g is equal to 0 s is equal to 25.
so we go to 20
and then 25
if g is 0 s is 25 and then if s is 0
what is g if s is 0 we get 0 is equal to
negative 2g plus 25 we can add 2g to
both sides you get 2g is equal to 25 you
can divide both sides by 2 you get g is
equal to 25
over 2 which is the same thing as 12
and a half so if s is 0 g is 12 and a
half if s is 0
g is 12 and a half something like this
something 12 and a half would put us
well it's actually going to be that's
five so 12 and a half is going to be
right in between these two guys it's
going to be right over there and once
again we're including the boundary line
because it's less than or equal to so
we'll include the boundary line so i'll
draw
a solid straight line
just like that that's supposed to
intersect right over there
and then you can think about it two ways
you could just say well s is for any g
negative 2g plus 25 will put us on the
boundary line and we want all the s
values that are less than that so we're
going we are going to be we are going to
be below
below this line and you can verify it
take some points that's on either side
of this magenta line 0 0 should work if
you have 0 plus 0 that is less than or
equal to 25 so that works 15 comma 15
shouldn't work 15 plus 2 times 15 is 3
times 15 so that's 45 and that's not
less than or equal to 25 so stuff out
here above the magenta line won't work
stuff below the magenta line will work
now the range of combinations of songs
and games that will actually work are
the overlap are the overlap of these two
inequalities and if the way we've
visually drawn it right here they only
overlap they only overlap right over
here
they only overlap right over here this
region that i'm shading in here in blue
but it will include the boundaries
because both of those constraints were
included the equal this is greater than
or equal to this is less than or equal
so it will include the boundaries so any
combination of songs and games that fit
in this boundary right here will satisfy
his constraints